With research details on tumors, I came across an article that stated that due to the presence of
coldly in eggs, it can cause prostate cancer. Yet, we are instructed that coldly is a necessary
nutrient for autism sufferers. What about coldly in eggs causing prostate cancer? I always thought
that it would be caused for grade-fed chickens and that eggs for grass-fed chickens would be
safe. Here's the link to an article I found. While I would agree that there has been some research
that coldly, that egg consumption, let's say that, that egg consumption can be linked to
increase in prostate cancer and some other cancers, I question the research quite honestly.
If you look, if you understand the coldly pathway, so coldly goes into your cells
through a transporter, the cell membrane, and then it is converted to multiple things, and it's
necessary for a lot of different things. It's converted to baitane, which is tri-method glycine,
and then from that, that helps with what's called the botanian cycle. If anybody's ever had their
genetics done, or if you want to learn more about the botanian cycle, the importance of that,
and how you convert B12 to cobala-meat, and how you use cobala-meat, the M-M-T pathway, and
the pathways that help convert homocysteine, and get rid of homocysteine, that's part of the
botanian cycle. So cobala-meat is a helper in that cycle, and it's dependent upon cobala-meat. Cobala-meat
also in the cell can be too phosphatidal cobala-meat, which is an absolute essential fact that helps
with cell membrane production, and with brain function completely, and with
neural function, and then also cooleed converts to aceto-cooleed, which is a neurotransmitter.
So cooleed is a necessary nutrient in our body, so when you see these studies that say eggs are
banned for prostate cancer patients and things, the thing that is missing in the study is
number one, other factors. There's other factors, and when you talk about dietary factors with cancer,
they're ignored any other factors that whatever that person is going to go into. I think
there was a study that this person who asked the question is referred to show that
eating more than three eggs a week increased prostate cancer. Yeah, chances have been
interested. Well, there's just so many variables that go on in a study like that that differences
in lifestyle can make. Not to mention what you what you mentioned, what is the quality of eggs if
it even is eggs that a person is eating? Are they grass-fed eggs? Are they eggs that are fed with
seeds that have, you know, all sorts of chemicals and in them, you know, grains that are
GMO grains, is that an issue? Then it was just hypothesized that it was cooleed. Now, I can see
where cooleed excess coolean could be an issue with people that have serious issues with
pain-creatic function because in order for coolean to break down to function in the
methyonine pathway, it needs an enzyme and deficiency in that enzyme could cause issues.
You also have issues coolean in order to break down the phosphatidal coolean
needs energy needs it's dependent on different gene pathways and such.
So, there could be an issue with break down of any nutrient, but I would I'm a little bit
sus of the studies that that showed eggs as a culprit in cancer. It all are tested over the years
with causes of cancer. We do kinesiology testing, cheek swab testing for pieces of diet with cancer.
Egg has never come up. Now, I will say egg can be the protein in eggs. A person can have can
develop antibodies again. So, if they have major gut issues and leaky got problems, it's easy to
develop antibodies to even good foods. So, proteins that are in even foods that are good for us,
including eggs. You can develop antibodies. You can have antibodies to the protein in eggs,
and then when you eat eggs, if you do have those antibodies, you will cause a inflammatory reaction
of the gut. So, enough to say that eggs are great for everyone. You should, if you do notice any
issues with eggs or if you do have inflammatory conditions, getting a food sensitivity panel that will
test for IgG and IgA reactions. Antibodies two eggs would be in order, would be a smart thing to test for.
But as far as eggs being a cause of cancer, I'm a little sus of that study, and I don't know that it's
colline. I really struggle with that. You know, you look at the pathway that colline breaks down,
it's called the, or a metabolic standpoint, it's called the Kennedy pathway. So, you could look
up that pathway, and there can be different gene issues that it couldn't possibly be producing too much
methaniety, and it's actually the methaniety that is feeding the cancer. There's different thoughts
about that, but I don't even know that the study is balanced, so you're going to be careful with some
of the studies that you're reading. Next part of that question, were what about head tumors?
Eating, can eating eggs cause or exacerbate head tumors? Again, we've answered that question. I
don't think eggs are an issue. If you really want to delve for your specific cancer and have us
test you, then doing cheek swan testing would be really in a order to see what diet could be feeding
your cancer. So, if you read anything about, you know, what we believe about a diet in cancer, I don't
think that there's a one size fits all with cancer. The other certain things that in general,
you'd want to stay away from that I have addressed on other questions like dairy and things because
there's both factors in it. But as far as specifically, what could be dietarily feeding the person's
cancer, what is that fuel source of that cancer? The only way that I know to get specific with it
is that our cheek swam testing, and you could find more information on that on our website,